[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
vous le savez pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts la
présidente de l'Assemblée prononce
l'irrecevabilité des amendements
d'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans et
les oppositions de la nuque au RN en
passant par le groupe liote à l'origine
de cette proposition de loi crie au déni
de démocratie est-ce justifié qui
cherche à Tordre notre Constitution le
Gouvernement ou ses opposants en en
débattra juste après ces titres et puis
dans trois quarts d'heure c'est le
portrait d'un ministre sous pression que
je vous propose
avec beaucoup de force que
je n'ai pas voulu viser le président
Marleix mais si mon geste a été mal
interprété je lui présente mes excuses
ainsi qu'à toutes leurs présentations
nationales
c'était le 7 mars dernier
Eric Dupond-Moretti s'excusait après
avoir fait un double bras d'honneur en
pleine hémicycle Olivier Marleix venait
de rappeler la mise en examen du
ministre pour prise illégale d'intérêt 3
mois plus tard ou en est cette procédure
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République de le quart de des sceaux
peut-il rester en place sa forte
personnalité fait-elle oublier là aussi
historique du budget de la justice qu'il
a obtenu ne ratez pas tout à l'heure
notre débat sur le bilan en Derrick du
pont Moretti place Vendôme mais d'abord
cette argument financier brandi pariel
Braun Pivet pour retoquer la loi visant
à abroger la retraite à 64 ans premières
explications signées Jonathan Dupriez
c'est une fin de partie à couteau tirée
qui s'annonce entre majorité
présidentielle et opposition au
lendemain d'une 14e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a tranchée elle fera barrage à
l'examen de la mesure d'abrogation des
64 ans qui devait être examiné demain au
Palais Bourbon pour justifier sa
décision Yaël Braun Pivet invoque
l'article 40 de la Constitution visant à
empêcher toute initiative par le menteur
créant une charge pour les finances
publiques sur ces amendements de
rétablissement de l'article 1 je suis
très clair ils seront déclarés
irrecevables par moi-même dans la
journée aujourd'hui et je suis en train
d'examiner l'ensemble des autres
amendements puisqu'il y aura évidemment
d'autres irrecevabilités cette décision
a fait bondir le groupe liotte à
l'origine de la proposition de loi pour
abroger la réforme mais aussi toutes les
oppositions il dénonce une attaque
inédite contre les droits du Parlement
voire même un déni de démocratie
ce que je ne suis pas et bien je ferai
en sorte de faire respecter le Parlement
de faire respecter les actifs
parlementaires et puis aller au vote
pourquoi avoir peur du vote quelle est
cette démocratie dans laquelle on a peur
du vote mais pour la droite alliée de
circonstances du gouvernement pour faire
passer la réforme des retraites la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale n'a
au contraire fait qu'appliquer à la
lettre la Constitution rien d'anormal
donc pour le président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher leur type 40 de la Constitution
les parlementaires le savent parfois le
déplore on ne crée pas de nouvelles
charges publiques par la loi sans
qu'elle soit pas simplement compensées
mais mais prévu donc l'application de
l'article 40 c'est tout simplement
l'application de notre Constitution
alors que l'épilogue autour des
retraites se profile le gouvernement
semble avoir remporté la bataille mais
après de multiples passages en force au
Parlement et face à une opinion publique
très hostile à la réforme c'est moi
écoulé risque d'altérer durablement la
confiance des Français envers l'exécutif
sommes-nous face à déni de démocratie
voilà la question que je pose à mes
invités Jean garrigue bonsoir vous êtes
historien président du comité de
l'histoire parlementaire auteur de ce
livre Élisée contre Matignon le couple
infernal de 58 à nos jours aux éditions
talandiers Mathilde Hitman patin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de droit
public à l'Université du Mans Bruno
pallier bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes directeur de recherche au CNRS
au Centre d'études européennes de
Sciences Po et auteur de ce livre
réformer les retraites publiée au presse
de Sciences Po justement qui retrace
l'historique de nos systèmes de retraite
j'accue également Mathieu croissanto
bonsoir Mathieu politique est-ce que
vous employez cette expression tiens
jean-garis démarre avec vous de déni de
démocratie pour qualifier la décision de
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
alors pour qualifier cette décision il
me semble abusif de parler de déni de
démocratie j'ai été parmi beaucoup
d'autres d'autres hostile à la manière
dont Emmanuel Macron avait proposé gérer
imposer sa réforme des retraites au
détriment d'une opinion publique et de
corps intermédiaires qui étaient
hostiles qui n'ont pas été consultés
suffisamment donc je suis très à l'aise
pour parler de ce cas précis de ce qui
se passe avec cette proposition de yacht
et je constate je suis obligé de
constater que les règles de la procédure
parlementaire de de dérouler
parlementaire que ça soit en commission
des affaires sociales ou avec ce qui va
se passer en séance plénière à mon sens
ont été respectés alors on peut
s'interroger sur la manière dont le
parlementarisme rationalisé en France
autorise précisément le pouvoir exécutif
à gêner le déroulement d'un processus
par le parlementaire
mais c'est un autre débat et moi je
pense c'est un débat intéressant il
faudrait peut-être réfléchir à la
manière de faire et notre nos
institutions et leurs fonctionnements
mais si on prend strictosensus ce qui
s'est passé dans cette dans cette
procédure à part la bataille
d'amendement qui qui s'est produit et
qui est du fait de la nups notamment une
forme d'obstruction une nouvelle
parlementaire
le passage aussi de l'obstruction en
commission des affaires sociales à
nouveau il y a eu cette tentative je ne
vois pas qu'il y ait eu quelque chose on
peut discuter évidemment de la
l'utilisation de de l'article 40 voilà
ça on peut discuter ok on va d'abord
être sur cette question de l'article 40
puis ensuite on va quand même élargir au
climat général autour de cette réforme
des retraites et à la façon dont
effectivement ce que la Constitution a
été utilisée ou pas tordu ou pas pour
reprendre l'expression que je j'avais
choisi pour mes titres on va peut-être
on fait pas mal de pédagogie dans cette
émission et vous êtes là pour nous aider
Mathilde Einstein cet article 40 on l'a
déjà expliqué mais en quelques mots
de quoi il consiste alors en quelques
mots l'article 40 précise qu'une
proposition ou un amendement
parlementaire donc tout ce qui est issu
des députés j'excuse gouvernement ne
peut pas soit diminuer les ressources
publiques ou créer ou aggraver une
charge publique donc de tradition on dit
que les députés peuvent diminuer les
ressources publiques à condition de
compenser cette diminution par une autre
ressource en revanche ne peuvent pas
créer ne serait-ce qu'une seule charge
publique même s'ils le compensait par
ailleurs ça c'est ce que dit la lettre
de la Constitution donc au moment du
dépôt du projet de loi il est possible
de refuser une proposition de loi du
projet je vous ai dit d'une proposition
de là il est possible de la refuser et
également au niveau des amendements
après vous l'avez pas refusé à la
première étape elle le fait est-ce que
justement et ça on va certainement en
discuter il y a une une souplesse au
niveau du de la pratique parlementaire
vous l'évoquiez qui est de ne pas
forcément retoquer comme on dit dans le
jargon toutes les propositions de loi
desquelles créent une charge publique
parce que sinon il n'y en aurait
quasiment aucune à condition qu'elle
soit ce qu'on appelle gagée ça veut dire
on crée quelque chose pour commencer on
a bien compris Bruno vous venez de
l'évoquer vous aussi mais il y a la
Constitution puis à l'esprit et ça c'est
important d'insister là-dessus peut-être
mais moi je pense quand j'enseignais le
droit constitutionnel on essayait
d'expliquer que les constitutions se
succédaient en France comment changer
souvent pour s'adapter à la conjoncture
politique pour la conjoncture politique
depuis quelques années elle a
considérablement changé d'abord il y a
la croyance qu'il faut donner plus de
pouvoir à l'opposition c'est ce que la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 et
puis il y a surtout une situation
inédite où on a un parlement qui dans la
composition ressemble à des résultats
électoraux de d'élections
proportionnelle en fait puisqu'on a
trois une tripartition en notre
Constitution elle a été pour
penser et faite par le général de Gaulle
et pour créer un bip parti vraiment avec
peut-être plusieurs parties dans la
majorité mais et là le gouvernement
fonctionne comme s'il a une majorité
comme si on était dans du bip artisme et
donc il essaye d'utiliser les
instruments qui ont fait avec été conçus
pour domestiquer tous les 40 là 49 47 40
pour domestiquer sa majorité si elle
était constituée de plusieurs parties là
c'est pour domestiquer voire faire taire
les deux oppositions donc il y a c'est
légal il respecte absolument la chose ça
n'a rien à voir avec le contexte présent
avec les tendances présentes et puis
surtout moi c'est ce qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est l'effet sur l'opinion
publique les faits sur les électeurs et
c'est l'affirmation la réaffirmation la
Réré affirmation si je puis dire que
quoi que vous pensiez quoi que vous
pensiez quoi que vous nous fassiez
savoir cette réforme passera malgré vous
contre vous et ça là on n'est pas dans
55 ans 52 49 on est dans des sondages
qui persistent qui sont extrêmement
stables je parle pas des mobilisations
et là il y a l'effet inflation l'effet
grève etc qui sont extrêmement simples
c'est les deux tiers de la population et
80 à 80% très actifs et qui disent il
n'est pas question de travailler dans
ces conditions c'est pas du tout une
vague de flemme et ça c'est pas entendu
et cette surdité elle est catastrophique
politiquement et en enverra des traces
déjà dans les sondages mais dans les
élections dans les prochaines élections
avec un autre sondage qui confirme la
tendance générale depuis des mois son
âge est là pour BFM TV 61% des personnes
interrogées pour que cette proposition
de loi liotte soit débattue et 64% qui
souhaitent qu'elle soit adoptées ça
c'est vraiment le dernier sondage qui
est tombé en cette fin d'après-midi Jean
garrigue
on place on utilise souvent et c'est un
argument qu'on ne peut pas non plus
totalement négliger cet argument des
sondages depuis 5 mois pour finalement
justifier aussi
de la part des oppositions leur action
au Parlement est-ce que enfin voilà
c'est une question de légitimité contre
représentativité on revient toujours à
cette cette question là il est vrai que
ça pose un problème je me suis moi-même
posé d'ailleurs en critiquant la méthode
la verticalité
jupitérienne ou d'Emmanuel Macron parce
que c'est vrai que on peut opposer à
cette critique de la verticalité le
caractère d'abord non constitutionnel et
assez flou de ce que constitue les
sondages bon il semblerait malgré tout
que l'opinion est clairement exprimée à
ce que les corps intermédiaires ça
c'était important dans la méthodologie
de la de la réforme et
ressenti ce manque d'explication et ce
manque de concertation et ça c'est très
important parce que dans notre tradition
des mots de pratique il y a d'un côté
les institutions mais il y a aussi de
l'autre côté des canaux d'expression de
la souveraineté populaire qui reste
quand même l'alpha et l'oméga la
souveraineté du peuple or en
l'occurrence y compris sous la Cinquième
République et en dépit de tous les
instruments que confère au pouvoir
exécutif les institutions
parlementarisme rationalisé il faut
écouter le peuple il faut et d'ailleurs
le principe même du général de Gaulle
qui pouvait s'appuyer sur sa légitimité
sur une majorité confortable c'était
aussi d'écouter les citoyens et là en
l'occurrence ils n'ont pas été écoutés
c'est quand même le vice originel de
cette de cette réforme Mathieu peut-être
votre avis là-dessus parce que écouter
le peuple est-ce que ça veut dire
écouter les sondages et et un an après
l'élection d'un Emmanuel Macron qui
avait quand même cette réforme à son
programme
chaussettes vous pouvez renverser c'est
pas c'est pas franchement avec ça qu'on
fait une démocratie on peut tenir compte
de l'opinion publique dans ces canaux
d'expression que ce soit dans les
mobilisations dans des tribunes dans les
médias dans les sondages quand elles
donnent son avis mais la légitimité pour
le coup le camp d'exécutif Emmanuel
Macron c'était dans son programme et
puis ensuite il y a des élections
législatives il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue mais le groupe le plus important
qui constitue une majorité relative
avait porté cette cette réforme et donc
il s'appuie sur cette légitimité qui est
la seule légitimité démocratique pour le
coup pour dire on a eu raison de faire
de faire cette réforme après là où je
rejoins Jean c'est que dans notre
société on a d'autres corps
démocratiques et notamment la démocratie
sociale avec des syndicalistes qui eux
aussi procèdent d'élection enfin j'ai
des élections pour pour les syndicats
dire représentatifs qui donc parlent pas
juste au nom de Laurent Berger ou
Philippe Martinez quand c'est eux qui
négocié mais oh non de leur demandant et
qui sont l'ensemble des salariés qui
votent aux élections professionnelles et
donc c'est vrai que l'exécutif n'a fait
aucun cas de cette démocratie sociale et
il a utilisé comme vous le disiez toutes
les armes du parlementarisme rationalisé
parce que la situation est
exceptionnelle donc l'accumulation du 47
ans du 49-3 de l'article 40 aujourd'hui
de l'article 38 au Sénat tout ça c'est
parce c'est des armes exceptionnelles
parce que la situation politique est
exceptionnelle c'est le doc je pense pas
qu'on puisse parler des démocraties en
France il y a un défaut politique il y a
défaut politique de la part de
l'exécutif dans la façon dont il a
conduit la réforme dans la façon dont il
a refusé d'entendre le message que lui
adressait les mobilisations populaires
et Dieu sait qu'il y en a eu on est à
14e journée oui ça s'essouffle mais
beaucoup de monde dans la rue et il y a
un défaut politique même dans la
conclusion qu'il tire de cette séquence
puisque l'idée c'est on passe à autre
chose maintenant c'est fait et voyez
bien on avait raison de toute façon on a
mobilisation c'est souffle il y a pas eu
de geste politique après une séquence
pour parler comme les communicants de
l'Élysée on parle toujours de séquence
c'est un mot affreux pardon d'avoir dit
après après
cette période on attendait un geste
politique fort et pour le coup ce geste
poétique se fait encore attendre on
l'attend encore il y a eu des
bilatérales avec d'entre la première
ministre et les représentants syndicaux
mais effectivement on peut pas parler de
geste politique fort je voudrais qu'on
entende à une première réaction dans
dans ce débat celle du président du
groupe liotte à l'Assemblée nationale
qui se dit concerner on écoute Bertrand
pencher nous considérons que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale n'a
rien fait pour maintenir les droits du
Parlement et au contraire elle a failli
en charge en faisant en sorte de
durablement affaiblir l'Assemblée
nationale et par conséquent porter un
coup très grave à la séparation des
pouvoirs en France qui est le fondement
même de toute démocratie c'est un
précédent qui affaiblit durablement le
le Parlement et la semaine national
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse Mathilde Hitman patin est-ce que
ça affaiblit durablement l'Assemblée ou
peut-être même plus généralement le
Parlement ça a été évoqué on est dans un
cas très spécifique avec une crise sans
précédent autour de la réforme des
retraites donc je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse tirer des conclusions intives
après pour revenir sur ce qui a été
évoqué sur le l'espèce de double branche
de l'analyse de cette question on a
d'abord la branche strictement juridique
et ça a été évoqué les règles de droit
sont respectées ça on est d'accord mais
il y a la branche politique qui
elle-même se décline en deux branches
avant juin 2022 et après juin 2022 et
c'est vrai qu'on le voit avec cette
réforme des retraites le pouvoir
exécutif et sa majorité
utilise toutes les armes prévues par la
Constitution pour justement
finir parvenir à ses fins et sur la
question de déni démocratie séparation
des pouvoirs il n'y a pas de mon point
de vue une atteinte à la séparation des
pouvoirs dans la mesure où juridiquement
les règles sont respectées dire qu'on
peut pas dire il y a une atteinte à la
séparation des pouvoirs de ce point de
vue là après d'un point de vue plus
politique et c'est pour ça que c'est
extrêmement compliqué cette question
mais c'est comme si on n'avait pas enfin
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez Bruno
paliers mais comme si les les parties
petites dans leur ensemble avaient pas
de tir on est un an quasiment un an
après législatives c'était le 19 juin le
le second tour comme si personne n'avait
vraiment tiré les leçons de ce scrutin
c'est clair que l'exécutif cherche à
faire croire qu'il a une majorité oui
mais de la part des oppositions aussi de
la part des oppositions il souhaite se
poser comme l'opposition qui va gagner
la prochaine alternance et donc on
n'arrive pas du tout à raisonner ils
auraient pu aussi être dans une logique
de pardon nous interrompre de de
la construction de majorité de packs de
gouvernement est un petit peu ça c'est
autour de
la motion de censure qui avait déposé
Eliott il y avait un accord là-dessus là
on va voir ce qui se passe demain il y a
un petit peu de ça l'intersyndical aussi
elle dit quelque chose quand même pas du
changement de monde dans lequel on
essaie quand même l'Union syndical c'est
tout à fait exceptionnel et voilà
peut-être que c'est l'exécutif qui va
être le dernier à réaliser que le monde
est en train de changer et qu'il faut
donc adapter les pratiques qui ne
peuvent plus être celle de la 5e
République impériale à l'aune de d'une
désagrégation vous vous dites il faut
changer de République là où il faut en
tout cas il faut la la rénover parce que
là on dit il y a des règles il y a
d'autres règles depuis notamment la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 qui
permettrait de donner plus de rôle à
l'opposition de participer mieux
aux discussions etc et puis là
clairement de toute façon ils le savent
bien s'ils avaient pas peur complètement
des règles qu'au Sénat ça passerait pas
puisqu'il y a encore une majorité
différente au Sénat moi ce que je pense
c'est que il y a de la fébrilité d'une
part le spectacle qui est donné quand
même une présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui dans un premier temps
vient ici ailleurs s'affirmer comme je
suis là pour faire respecter le
Parlement se fait tirer les oreilles à
l'Elysée enfin tout le monde l'a vu ça a
été vous l'avez raconté tout le monde
l'a raconté et changer radicalement de
discours on disait les règles respectées
moi je sais pas si c'est dans les règles
de choisir ceux qui vont voter puisque
le gouvernement dit donc là il y a eu un
mal de ce qui s'est passé en commission
des affaires sociales on va essayer
d'être aussi puisque en ce moment la
majorité communique là-dessus dire il y
a eu un vote de députés désolé vous avez
perdu le numéro je rappelle que pendant
la nuit précédant ce vote ils ont choisi
les membres qui comme ça siégé à la
conscience comme ça se fait couramment
moi si vous voulez je suis père si je
donne des mauvais exemples à mes enfants
il faut pas m'étonner que mes enfants
aient pas envie de respect alors là je
vais vous donner la parole aux uns et
aux autres je vous propose d'entendre la
première ministre Elisabeth Bank puisque
justement elle réagissait au lendemain
de ceux de ce vote de la Commission des
affaires des social on écoute la
première ministre on analyse après ce
texte vous le savez monsieur le
Président est anticonstitutionnel et
personne n'est dupe de la man
œuvre et monsieur le Président Gautard
vous appelez au respect du Parlement au
débat je vous renvoie à ces principes ce
matin la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale a voté
et à supprimer l'article de la
proposition de loi qui visait à abroger
la réforme des retraites c'est un vote
clair et démocratique mais immédiatement
après
laupes a répondu par l'obstruction avec
le dépôt de 3000 sous amendements pour
empêcher un vote finale en commission
la réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction
chacun se renvoie les arguments de de
tordre la constitution ou de l'utiliser
pour pour faire de l'obstruction on
reviendra sur le rôle de la de la dupe
et de et de les films effectivement ce
switch pardon de langue lycisme pratiqué
par le parti LR qui a demandé à des
députés qui étaient hostiles à la
réforme des retraites de ne pas être là
en commission des affaires sociales pour
les remplacer par par d'autres oui par
des bourrins comme l'a dit François
Ruffin et je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que
cette manière de parler des pratiques
parlementaires soit à l'honneur d'abord
de François Ruffin et surtout aide à une
meilleure compréhension et appréhension
par les citoyens de cette vie
parlementaire il a parlé aussi de
combine et de magouille à propos de ce
qui s'était passé et là aussi c'est
c'est quoi c'est légal c'est inhabituel
ce qui s'est passé en commission tout à
fait habituel de la manière que
d'utiliser l'article 40 c'est quelque
chose de très traditionnel je dirais
alors je dis pas que c'est souhaitable
et on sait très bien de quelle manière
le pouvoir exécutif puis à l'échelle de
du Parlement on a essayé de corseter le
débat mais je pense que l'objectivité
oblige quand même à dire j'en suis
désolé que les responsabilités sont un
tout petit peu partagées dans cette dans
cette affaire et que précisément ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui à l'issue des
élections de 2022 la structure ternaire
de ce Parlement et surtout une structure
dans laquelle vous avez deux forces
politiques qui sont qu'on le veuille ou
non dans l'état actuel les choses qui ne
sont pas des forces d'alternance qui ne
sont pas des forces de gouvernement et
qui sont des forts de protestation
perturbent de manière incontestable avec
notamment la stratégie de conflictualité
qui est celle de la nupes mais pas
seulement parce qu'on pourrait voir
aussi ce que ce qui est fait ou n'est
pas fait par le Front national par le
rassemblement
[Musique]
favorable à la majorité ils auraient
fait la même chose à sa place personne
ne peut juré le contraire bien sûr
qu'ils auraient fait la même chose et
ils s'attendaient quand même pas à ce
que il y a le droit de pivée finissent
par tirer au bazooka contre son propre
camp et puis troisième étage évidemment
l'exécutif et la majorité qui fin de pas
voir le problème ah bah oui mais quoi on
a respecté les règles tout est
réglementaires on a respecté la
Constitution c'est vrai aussi mais enfin
sur ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure il y
a un problème politique quand même
particulier dans une situation poétique
particulière donc ils auraient dû tirer
évidemment
c'est entre guillemets facile ça peut
être voilà j'entends le j'entends
l'opinion de de cibler uniquement le
l'exécutif moi ce que j'ai entendu il y
a pas des tâches pour le rassemblement
national il faut rien parce qu'ils
savent que ça va engrange quoi ils
engrange et donc là il y a une
responsabilité je suis vraiment d'accord
avec tout le monde partagé de la partie
UPS et la partie exécutif mais le
problème c'est qu'ils savent qu'ils sont
en train de danser sur un volcan ils le
savent parfaitement enfin toutes les
toutes les indications
et pas seulement sondage mais moi je
patience pour il y a cegipov sur qui
analyse très profondément la crise de
confiance le rejet des institutions et
des élites et donc des institutions si
elles permettent aux élites de jouer ce
ballon et ça moi c'est ça qui est que je
trouve extrêmement grave c'est de
continuer à jouer comme avant alors que
la situation n'est pas comme avant je
t'avais déjà rappelé ici moi je tiens à
le rappeler il y avait 20 millions de
voix d'écart entre Jacques Chirac et
Jean-Marie Le Pen en 2017 il y avait 10
millions de voix d'écart entre Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen et en 2022 il y
en avait cinq millions donc vous voyez
la droite elle est toute tracée et donc
là c'est vraiment très grave que tout le
monde continue comme si de rien n'était
alors que c'est un enjeu qui concerne la
population alors que la crise de la
confiance dans la démocratie est
extrêmement élevée alors que
l'alternative est là et que
l'alternative on la connaît c'est ce
qu'ils appellent la démocratie il
libérale on l'a vu un peu avec Trump on
la voit avec Orban on la voit avec donc
les alliés du rassemblement national
voilà c'est tout est présent et c'est
vraiment tout à fait choquant que les
uns comme les autres continuent à danser
comme comme la dit Mathieu croissanto
mais rassemblement national ne danse pas
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils sont pas
grand chose à faire ils font des choses
ils disent toujours voter pour nous
Marine Le Pen l'avait dit et ils disent
toujours moi je défends l'opposition est
très fort parce que je défends une
partie de mon électoral les ouvriers les
employés qui travaillent et si ça suffit
alors je vous dis intervenir allez les
livres pour quelques éléments sur la
crise de la démocratie vous l'avez
évoquée et c'est vrai qu'il y a une
revendication croissante de la
population de participer plus
directement et finalement on a mis de
côté la représentation parlementaire et
la population ne se sent pas
suffisamment représentées aussi parce
qu'il y a des situations comme ça ou ben
on a l'impression que le Parlement est
complètement lié sauf que le pouvoir
exécutif à chercher à donner
l'impression de donner la parole au
peuple avec beaucoup de d'éléments comme
le grand débat les comités etc les la
convention pour le climat qui finalement
ne donne rien derrière donc finalement
toutes les toutes les portes
festival de la refondation
donc finalement toutes les portes se
ferment c'est-à-dire qu'on donne
l'impression qu'on donne la voie
directement mais en fait non et d'un
point de vue parlementaire et bien on a
aussi les portes qui se qui semblent
fermées alors je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur
l'esprit et la loi l'usage de cet
article 40 grâce à mathiasarayz qui va
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir
Mathias bonsoir traditionnellement les
propositions de l'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale lors de leur niche
parlementaire bénéficie d'une certaine
souplesse vis-à-vis de cet article 40
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
communément une tradition parlementaire
sans cela la quasi-totalité des
propositions de loi tomberait sous le
coup de l'article 40 de la Constitution
puisque souvent créatrice de nouvelles
dépenses alors beaucoup face à ces
dépenses apportent ce qu'on appelle un
gage censé compenser les pertes sur le
budget de l'État d'ailleurs l'une des
garanties qui est souvent invoquée c'est
le gage tabac qui prévoit d'augmenter la
taxation sur les cigarettes une sorte de
carte blanche un peu passe-partout qui
est en réalité très flou puisqu'on ne
sait pas très bien ce temporaire
rapporter oui moi ça ne me gêne pas je
n'ai jamais fumé est-ce que c'est la fin
de ces exceptions en tout cas certains
politiques s'en a un qui atteint le 30
mai dernier au moment de juger recevable
cette proposition de loi du groupe
lyaute le président de la commission des
finances Éric Coquerel avait énuméré les
quelques contre-exemples depuis la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 alors
le député insoumis en compte 28 28
saisons de la commission des finances
c'est-à-dire qu'on lui demande son avis
sur la recevabilité du texte au total
sur ces 28 saisines seules 2 ont été
jugés ils recevables par la Commission
en 15 ans donc pour le reste c'est
grosso modo moitié-moitié entre
recevabilité partielle et recevabilité
totale les recevabilité à venir de la
main de la présidente de l'Assemblée
Yelle brun Pivet et donc pour savoir une
première et qu'en est-il ici au Sénat
alors le Sénat n'applique aucune
souplesse en matière de rigueur
budgétaire une autre tradition qui
figure dans le règlement du Sénat
article 45 comme la rappeler ce mercredi
après-midi sur notre antenne le sénateur
LR René Paul Savary un brin avec les
députés nous aussi on connaît l'article
40 plus que le Sénat est beaucoup plus
rigoureux et moi ce que je repose
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de faire
preuve régulièrement de l'excisme quand
on voit en commission tous les les
députés qui peuvent siéger non ça se
produit pas au Sénat nous on est habitué
à travailler les articles en profondeur
pas faire de dépenses supplémentaires
article 40 pas être hors sujet article
47 45 et en conséquence ne se pose pas
de problème personne ne remet en cause
des décisions qui sont prises une nuance
avec l'Assemblée nationale basée en
réalité avant tout sur la responsabilité
vous l'avez entendu car sur le plan
réglementaire les deux chambres sont
tenues de faire respecter l'article 40
de la Constitution à la lettre merci
Mathias Jean Garry je regarde je reviens
vers vous sur la justification
budgétaire peut-être pour élargir un peu
le spectre cet argument est-ce qu'il est
encore audible par les Français après
des années de quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
quand même compliqué de de mettre ça en
avant aujourd'hui juste en préambule ça
me fait sourire
réflexion du sénateur parce qu'en fait
c'est un vieux débat mais depuis les
débuts de la Troisième République où les
sénateurs les sages élus suffrage
indirect et notable critiquaient
l'assemblée qui à chaque fois à la
Chambre des députés qui à chaque fois
aggravel la lourdeur du déficit bref
c'est toujours bien c'est une vieille
histoire ok vraiment séculaire et donc
ce porte d'Oxy budgétaire quoi qu'il en
coûte évidemment pour l'opinion publique
aujourd'hui après ce passage de du quoi
qu'il en coûte c'est un argumentaire on
le voit bien on l'a vu dans dans toute
cette campagne de sur la l'explique
d'explication du gouvernance ça
n'explique c'est quelque chose qui ne
passe pas c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus difficile à comprendre bon
il y a d'ailleurs eu d'autres
propositions alternatives qui ont qui
ont pas été entendus qui n'ont pas été
écoutés par le pouvoir exécutif mais
c'est vrai que cet argumentaire là
aujourd'hui passe beaucoup moins bien
bon c'est pas une raison pour que
l'exécutif n'en tienne pas compte je
veux dire pour que ça soit avancé par
l'exécutif sur le long terme peut-être
que les perles à rigueur les pinets
bérégovoye Raymond Barre ont aussi
acquis une stature historique parce que
précisément ils incarnaient cette idée
de la de la rigueur budgétaire donc
voilà mais à court terme c'est vrai que
c'est une idée qui qui voilà qui passe
beaucoup moins bien et que donc cette
cette idée de l'article la justification
de l'article 40 peut être moins bien
reçue par la population la majorité
présidentielle qui se retranchent
derrière l'application de la
Constitution on l'a dit il y a un fait
le report de las légal à 64 ans n'aura
jamais été formellement discuté par les
députés cet article 7 c'est ce que
regrettait Laurent Berger hier dans la
manifestation parisienne on peut pas
changer la vie de millions et 2 millions
de travailleurs et travailleuses de
citoyens sans un moment donné avoir un
vote dans la représentation nationale et
ce vote il n'aura pas eu lieu ni sur
l'article 7 ni sur le vote global de la
loi
là sur la PPL qui a été déposé par le
rookiote et ça pose un problème
donc Laurent Berger il rappelle aussi
Bruno pallier ce qui s'est passé au
début je trouve que c'est intéressant
aussi de le rappeler dans un débat sur
le fonctionnement de notre démocratie
c'est le le blocage même si là encore
c'est parfaitement légal l'utilisation
des amendements qui est la stratégie de
la nupes et surtout de LFI de ne pas
aller jusqu'à l'article 7 qui prévoyait
le passage à 64 ans d'ailleurs Laurent
Berger ça l'avait eu serré ça il faut
c'est assez surprenant puisque le
visiblement les calculs politiques
étaient pas les mêmes puisque il
s'agissait de ne pas aller à l'article 7
par peur qui soit voté et là maintenant
il s'agit parce qu'ils sont sûrs c'est
quand même un peu gonflé on reprend le
bal des hypocrites donc par les Mathieu
tout à l'heure de aujourd'hui dire ah là
là c'est insupportable on va pas
discuter de cette article sur les 64 ans
et puis avoir empêché il y a quelques
mois de le faire moi ce que je trouve
surtout insupportable c'est qu'on se
demande pas un sérieusement pourquoi les
causes de ce qui se passe actuellement
et
on en parle pas aujourd'hui de pourquoi
il y a cette opposition et pourquoi il y
a cette rupture entre l'obstination du
gouvernement et une majorité des
Français une grosse majorité des
Français qui dit effet savoir je ne veux
pas travailler plus longtemps dans ces
conditions et je pense qu'il faut
absolument aujourd'hui et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on obtenu les syndicats
continuer à approfondir la question du
travail bien sûr
donc moi j'essaye d'y contribuer avec
beaucoup de collègues on peut documenter
le fait que les conditions de travail ce
sont des gradés que un certain nombre de
choses sont moins bien en France
qu'ailleurs et c'est pas que des
représentations subjectives il y a 790
accidents du travail mortel par an en
France 470
000 par an il y a un nombre de Burn Out
beaucoup plus élevé en France que dans
d'autres pays européens ça s'explique ça
s'explique par une organisation du
travail un mode de management qui
intensifie qui met la pression qui gère
par les chiffres parlons de cela parce
que ça fait plusieurs fois sur ce
plateau c'est important de le rappeler
quand on est dans un débat sur les
recettes mais est-ce qu'il y a la
fenêtre d'opportunité pour le faire là
maintenant et si ça je pense j'essaie de
la rouvrir encore une fois sur votre
plateau c'est que un des grands acquis
de ce mouvement c'est que le
gouvernement n'a pas réussi à dire c'est
des flemmards ils veulent juste partir
en vacances Darmanin essayer de le faire
au début du mois de janvier maintenant
et les abeilles band le dit bien il y a
un souci avec le travail il faut qu'on
en parle la fenêtre s'est ouverte
maintenant et elle va rester normalement
ouverte si Elisabeth borne en tout cas
reste à sa place jusqu'en décembre et
donc il est essentiel d'en parler parce
que là autant on a bien notre sensation
qu'on est bloqué politiquement avec
cette tripartition on voit pas de c'est
pas une vraie majorité il y a pas de
vrai opposition autant sur le travail il
y a plein de choses à faire on peut
vraiment changer l'organisation on peut
introduire de la démocratie dans les
entreprises on peut demander aux
salariés de participer aux décisions ils
sont pas contre les patrons les ils
veulent juste qu'on les reconnaît c'est
qu'on leur demande leur avis donc il y a
des choses à faire et ça il y a une
opportunité est-ce que la porte est
vraiment ouverte du côté de l'exécutif
là-dessus sur le travail sur le une
grande une espèce de une conférence
sociale a priori il déteste ça Emmanuel
Macron les grandes conférences sociales
c'est dit que ça sert à rien et pour le
coup on peut pas non plus lui donner
complètement tort parce que c'est vrai
que ce sont dans ces grands messes
sociales on est souvent figés dans des
postures en revanche il y a une volonté
d'avancer affichée en tout cas par
l'exécutif qui considère qu'il doit se
sortir de tous bazar justement par par
une vraie réflexion et des vraies
mesures sur le travail est-ce qu'ils
iront aussi loin que le
veulent les syndicats se souvient de
leur berger qui a dit ça va vous coûter
cher très cher
ça suppose que l'Inter syndical reste
reste unique aussi cette force là c'est
pas l'exécutif qui va décider de ce qui
se passe dans les entreprises dans les
services publics c'est que là c'est une
question qui a géré aussi localement
avec les managers avec les RH avec les
syndicats avec les salariés donc il y a
beaucoup plus d'actions ça ne relève pas
que de la responsabilité d'ailleurs ce
qui pourrait faire des choses l'un de
nos invités sur ce plateau nous disait
qu'au niveau local le le la logique de
d'union syndicale elle commença va
s'appliquer elle avait aussi des effets
sur certaines négociations je reviens
rapidement le temps Philippe vite sur
cette question de l'article 7 donc
l'article 7 qui était dans la dans la
réforme initiale parce que tout le monde
fait comme si il avait jamais été
examiné il faut quand même rappeler
qu'il a été examiné au Sénat et après la
loi a été examinée au Sénat voilà c'est
pas neutre de le dire là aussi des
procédures de votre blog on est d'accord
ça a été quand même discuté et on peut
considérer qu'il y a eu aussi un vote
puisqu'il y a eu le vote de la motion de
censure qui était dès qu'il découlait
qui dérivait de l'usage du 49-3 et donc
du blocage institutionnel mais tout ça
c'est évidemment jouer sur les mots
fondamentalement ça a été ça a été une
affaire qui qui n'a pas suffisamment
donné place à une un débat démocratique
dans la société française insuffisamment
aussi au Parlement et pour rebondir ce
que vous disiez cette réforme des
retraites mon la dit souvent sur ce
plateau aurait dû être précédé
précisément par une grande consultation
avec les partenaires sociaux autour de
la question du travail au-delà de la
question des retraites toutes les
questions que posent le travail dans
notre société puisque c'est au fond
derrière tout ça ceci est allemand c'est
ça qui est en jeu on le voit bien avec
les conséquences de la de la crise du
covid la manière dont le télétravail
dont la motivation au travail a changé
pour les jeunes générations en bref tout
ça c'est des problèmes de fond et
malheureusement pour l'instant ils n'ont
pas été traités alors dans ce débat sur
la question des lignes démocratie ou pas
il y a aussi une question d'équilibre
des pouvoirs au sein de cette
Constitution de la Cinquième République
et du rôle du président du Sénat ou de
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
évidemment on est au cœur de cette
question ce soir Mathieu on va écouter
avant de vous donner la parole une
réaction celle de Mathilde panneau
présidente du groupe parlementaire RFI à
l'Assemblée c'était ce matin
donc moi je pose la question de savoir
si madame yelbrunfilez est toujours apte
à présider cette assemblée parce que il
faut bien comprendre que il y a le
brunchyver a une fonction de présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale et en tant que
telle elle doit être la garante de la
séparation des pouvoirs or aujourd'hui
très clairement elle a failli puisque
elle a décidé d'obéir aux ordres qui
étaient faits par le président et le
gouvernement et c'est contraire à ce que
doit faire une présidente de l'Assemblée
ce qui doit être à la hauteur de sa
fonction donc je suis très inquiète de
ce qui est en train de se passer
à la hauteur de sa fonction ben elle est
entre deux feux il y a le bon de pivée
entre deux feux de par sa fonction
d'abord entre le feu du Parlement la
foudre de l'Élysée elle est entre deux
feux de par la situation politique
ensuite entre cette majorité relative et
des oppositions très remontées et puis
elle est entre deux feux de par son
tempérament j'ai envie de dire enfin
elle qui se disait jusqu'à l'orguidée
par deux principes qui pourraient
paraître contradictoires jusqu'à
l'oxymore la loyauté et la liberté
longtemps à présent de l'Assemblée
pensez pouvoir avancer sur une ligne de
crête mais la tension était trop forte
sur ce qui est devenu le texte phare du
quinquennat pour continuer à jouer les
équilibristes après avoir résisté aux
pressions de moins en moins amicale de
son propre camp quand même il faut le
dire qui lui intimait depuis plusieurs
semaines de torpiller à tout prix cette
proposition du groupe club pour clôturer
enfin ce modifeuilleton des retraites
elle a donc choisi de dégainer l'article
40 de la Constitution pour éviter de
voir resurgir un amendement et donc un
vote demain dans l'hémicycle au risque
d'y laisser des plumes et un peu de sa
crédibilité oui la voilà des peintres
maintenant en courroie de transmission
et d'une certaine façon c'est un comble
elle qui s'est fait quand même une place
toute seule et depuis seulement 6 ans
dans le marigot politique élu puis
brillamment réduit il faut le dire dans
sa circonscription des Yvelines il y a
le droit de Pivet ne doit en effet rien
à personne et surtout pas Emmanuel
Macron c'est seul et sans soutien de
l'Elysée qu'elle est allée chercher
oculo la présidence de la commission des
lois lors de la présidente législatures
seul encore qu'elle a décroché le
perchoir pour devenir la première
première femme présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale en juin dernier alors que le
palais de l'Elysée avait tenté de
l'extré en la nommant au gouvernement
comme on donne un hochet depuis elle a
mené sa barque gagné l'estime de son
homologue au Sénat lui aussi élu des
Yvelines Gérard Larcher en défendant les
droits du Parlement quitte à froisser
l'exécutif et sa majorité ça neutralité
affiché lui-même permis de gagner dans
un premier temps une forme de respect
bienveillant de la part des oppositions
jusqu'à évidemment ce que les débats au
Palais Bourbon se tendent sur la réforme
des retraites au mois de février
on a toujours le choix dans l'absolu
mais en politique il y a aussi un
principe de réalité puis en plus les
excès de l'opposition criant à la dérive
mafieuse ont achevé de la convaincre que
la position était intenable la voici
donc aujourd'hui caricaturer en
incarnation de ce fameux parlementarisme
rationalisé dont on parle depuis le
début de cette émission elle a encore
c'est un comble elle publiait en 2021 en
décembre 2021 25 propositions pour un
parlement renforcé un chignon en vous
disant voilà onzième je propose
d'instaurer une instance qui soit
spécifiquement dédiée au contrôle de la
recevabilité des amendements le contrôle
serait centralisé et harmonisé pour
toutes les commissions et la séance
publique la légitimité la qualité du
contrôle en sortirait sans une doute
renforcée elle a pas eu le temps de
mettre ça en place à l'urait retirer une
épine du pied et évidemment je récon
termine quand même ce qui nous reste 3
minutes ça a filé très vite ce qui est
toujours bon signe dans un débat sur ce
qui peut se passer dans les prochains
jours puisque on a entendu Mathilde pano
elle a également annoncé le dépôt d'une
nouvelle motion de censure Mathilde
hensman patin là aussi un peu de
pédagogie qu'est-ce qui se passe si la
motion recueille la majorité absolue
soit 289 voix ou plus et bien si la
notion recueille la majorité absolue
alors le gouvernement est renversé tout
simplement tout simplement encore
faut-il mais ça l'oblige pas email
Macron à convoquer de nouvelles
élections législatives ah non si si les
choses clairement et ça n'oblige pas
Emmanuel Macron a convoqué de nouvelles
élections législatives mais il peut
prendre la décision après une motion de
censure comme l'avait fait général de
Gaulle la seule fois où un gouvernement
a été renversé de dissoudre derrière
l’assemblée nationale et de renvoyer de
renvoyer aux électeurs Jean Garry est-ce
qu'elle a une chance de passer cette
notion de censure
je suis pas prophète mais mais la
dernière elle n'est pas passée très très
loin
me semble pas que que le comment dire le
paysage est sensiblement évolué depuis
depuis l'échec de la précédente de toute
manière on voit bien s'il y a ce qu'il y
a motion de censure et quel pour quelle
majorité alternative dans cette ce
paysage ternaire dont on décrivait tout
à l'heure comment imaginer une
alternative avec d'un côté laupes et de
l'autre côté le rassemblement national
qui sont malgré tout aux antipodes l'un
de l'autre bien que certains disent
qu'ils soient proches sur certains
thèmes donc voilà on est dans dans une
impasse politique très très clairement
sauf à conclure ce fameux contrat de
gouvernement dont on parlait dont on a
parlé à un moment entre la majorité
macroniste et les républicains ce qui
apparaît là aussi aujourd'hui très
hypothétique donc voilà on est quand
même dans une impasse et alors une
dissolution serait catastrophique pour
au moins pour Emmanuel Macron et pour
les républicains qui perdraient aussi
des plumes assez rapidement
il y a toujours dit si émotion de
censure je dissout comme accident
on voit bien qui aurait à perdre mais on
voit pas très bien qui aurait gagné
vous êtes vous êtes moins affirmatif que
nous affirmatif pourquoi
parce que une campagne législative il
peut se passer des choses et c'est très
difficile de dire aujourd'hui tout le
monde se dit oh là là ça ressemble à un
national qui qui gagne une campagne
législative ça crée une dynamique et
les règles font qu'elles se rétraite
est-ce qu'il y aurait vraiment une
dynamique de campagne gagnant ça veut
pas dire 97 personnes
[Musique]
augmenter le nombre de députés et rendre
le l'assemblée encore plus difficile à
gouverner encore plus qui poussera à ce
que vous dites à une alliance de
gouvernement qui serait normalement la
logique de la société ce serait une
alliance entre LR et la majorité et la
matrice ensemble ça serait tenir compte
tous ensemble merci à tous on termine
là-dessus je rappelle le les titres de
vos livres Jean garrig elisé contre
Matignon publié chez Talandier et Bruno
pallier réformé les retraites c'est au
presse de Sciences Po merci encore
d'avoir participé à ce débat et à
bientôt sur sens public